Evidemment Shirley, je vais te mentaliser après.
Ça c'est sûr.
Mais avant, je ne t'ai pas fait venir que pour rien.
J'essaye de m'intéresser à cet univers là. Je regarde tes vidéos depuis...février maintenant.
Et je cherche des conseils pour moi.
-D'accord.
-En tant que mec, si tu veux.
Et je ne trouve pas grand chose.
Alors que je suis sûr que les meufs comme toi, vous avez pleins de vrais conseils.
-Ouais.
-Ok, donc cette vidéo, va être sur des conseils beauté sur moi avant la mentalisation.
Si jamais vous ne voulez pas voir ça, c'est pas la peine de le dire dans les commentaires. [rires]
Arrêtez de regarder cette vidéo ! [rires]
-Tout simplement, vous avez le droit.
Mais, il y a 30% de filles sur ma chaine, et je suis sûr que parmi les mecs, il y a des mecs qui comme moi, ont des problèmes de peau, de cheveux, de j'en sais rien...
-Sans trop en faire ! On a pas parlé de maquillage, ou rien de...
-Ah non !
-Non, non, non...
-Ah, on ne me maquillera pas ?!
-Ah non, simple. Oui... Je ne suis pas...
-Ah... Bon... Tant pis !
[rires]
Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Shirley de la chaine "Je suis Modeste".
-Hey !
-Comme moi aussi je suis modeste, on s'est dit ce serait peut-être cool de faire une vidéo ensemble.
Alors Shirley, toi tu as une chaine sur l'hypnose.
-Exactement.
-[rires] Pas du tout !
-J'hypnotise les gens avec la beauté.
-Là je viens de leur faire un ascenseur émotionnel de: Ah ouais ! Une hypnose, en plus une fille ! Trop bien !
Non, c'est une chaine beauty. Tu fais un peu de DIY aussi je crois ?
-Je fais beaucoup de DIY, en fait le truc c'est que je fais tous mes cosmétiques maison.
-Nous on s'est rencontré via une amie commune, Laetitia.
-Oui ! De la chaine, "Le Corps, La Maison, L'Esprit".
-Oui, "Le Corps, La Maison, L'Esprit".
Et on avait fait une vidéo qui est juste là.
Ensemble, au tout début de la chaine j'avais fait ça.
Après elle m'a dit:
"Hé Fabien, il faut absolument que tu rencontres Shirley. [rires]
Parce que Shirley, elle est trop gentille ! Parce que moi je trouve tout le monde trop gentil de toute manière !" [imite voix féminine]
On s'est rencontré comme ça.
-Ouais.
-Et du coup on a monté un network.
Notre network c'est des conversations Facebook à trois.
-Exactement, à trois. Juste à trois. Vous ne pouvez pas vous incruster c'est mort !
-Tu m'observes, tu m'analyses, et tu dis ce que tu peux faire pour moi. [rires]
-Non, parce que si je constate des problèmes que toi t'as pas vu c'est chaud...!
[rires]
T'imagines le malaise !
-Elle va me créer des complexes !
J'ai comme une marque, une démarcation...
-Ca c'est tout simplement tes cheveux, c'est le bronzage.
Oui, parce qu'en fait le soleil il tape...
-Oui c'est ça !
-Donc tu bronzes là...
-Après il faut que je sortes en mettant des barrettes ?! [rires]
-Voilà ! Ou tu te fais un serre-tête. Il y a des DIY pour ça sur YouTube. Tu te fais un joli serre-tête et voilà.
-C'est parti, DIY serre-tête, mec !
-Et tu mets mon super gel avec un serre-tête c'est... c'est mignon !
-Elle m'a offert un gel à la fraise qu'elle a fait elle-même !
-Ouais.
-Du coup j'ai pas osé demander les ingrédients, pour faire du gel.
[rires]
C'est trop chelou !
Alors, mon vrai problème, j'ai la peau très sèche. J'ai mis du Nivea ce matin.
-Ah ouais... Mais le Nivea c'est pas super bon non plus. En fait t'as du... Je vais commencer à être chiante...
T'as de l'huile minérale dedans en fait qui te permet de faire un gros film sur ta peau, donc ça va la protéger des agressions.
Mais tout ce que tu vas essayer d'apporter: hydratation, nutrition, tout ce dont tu as besoin, ça va rester en surface en fait.
Et tout ce que tu fais, ça ne sert à rien !
D'accord. Bon... Je vais aller me jeter par la fenêtre !
-Voilà !
[rires]
-Mais comme je suis au rez-de-chaussée, je vais rester du coup !
-Il faudrait exfolier ta peau. Et en fait pour l'hydrater...
-Exfolier ?
Alors attention ! Parce qu'on utilise des termes que je ne connais pas ! [rires]
-Alors exfolier, c'est simple. Tu prends... Il y a "Le Corps, La Maison, L'Esprit", en plus qui fait des trucs simples comme ça.
Tu prends du sucre.
-Ouais.
-Tu prends de l'huile.
Parce exemple, de l'huile d'olive. C'est mortel.
Tu t'exfolies la peau. En fait tu prends le sucre, au creux de ta main, tu mets un peu d'huile, mais un tout petit peu,
tu vas tout doucement frotter,
et le sucre va se dissoudre.
Là tu vas enlever toutes les cellules mortes, etc. Tu vas avoir bonne mine, tu vas être...
-Magnifaïk !
Tu vas être magnifaïk !
-Et ensuite pour l'hydrater en fait ce qui est chiant, surtout qu'on est à Paris, t'as le calcaire.
Il faut prendre une eau florale.
Tu sais ce que c'est une eau florale ?
-Bien sûr...
-Un hydrolat quoi !
-Tu vois les fleurs ?
-Ouais.
-Tu vois de l'eau ?
-Voilà une eau florale !
-Ok, d'accord. C'est ça. Voilà.
L'eau en fait, c'est éviter totalement de rentrer en contact, avec l'eau qui sort de ton robinet, c'est chiant...
-C'est drôle parce que je suis sûr que tous les mecs de cette chaine ce disent comme moi: "Je suis désydrater, alors je vais mettre de l'eau !", tu vois.
-Et non, en fait ça déshydrate encore plus. Plus tu mets de l'eau, plus ça déshydrate.
-C'est pour ça que quand tu sors de ta douche, des fois deux minutes après t'es...
-Ca tiraille.
Oui, ça tiraille. Et en fait, l'eau qui reste sur le visage et cetera, il faut tout de suite l'éponger.
Pas l'essuyer, l'éponger.
Parce que si tu l'as garde, c'est un truc très bizarre... Plus la peau absorbe, plus c'est n'importe quoi !
L'eau calcaire, du robinet, tu laisses tomber !
Ta Nivea, tu laisses tomber !
C'est mort !
Et hydrater ta peau avec une vraie crème.
-Mais c'est quoi une vraie crème du coup ?
-Sinon, je t'en fait une.
-Tu m'en fais une...T'en fais sur ta chaine ?
-Oui j'en fais pleins.
-Alors je vais voir sur ta chaine en fait, directement.
-Oui, tu l'as fait. C'est très très simple. Et la protéger du soleil.
-Oh, là, écoutes...
J'habite à Paris...
[rires]
-C'est assez compliqué, il pleut.
Mais on ne sait jamais. On est l'été, donc peut-être qui va se dire, je sors un petit peu.
-On est le 21. C'est l'été aujourd'hui en plus.
J'ai une deuxième question. Enfin une deuxième question...et je pense que d'autres personnes sur la chaine ont ce problème !
Dites le nous dans les commentaires.
J'ai le cheveu hyper sec en fait, on dirait du foin en fait.
-L'eau, du calcaire !
-Ouais, c'est ça !
[rires]
-L'eau, du calcaire, c'est mort !
-Non, mais en fait j'ai un problème quand je me lave les dents...
L'eau, du calcaire !
Je mets Head and Shoulders.
-C'est de la merde.
-Oh !
[rires]
Il faut que je jète tout !
-Non, c'est pas bon. En fait dedans, c'est un ingrédient, même des gels douche etc. il faut s'en séparer, c'est horrible.
C'est le Sodium Laureth Sulfate.
C'est un cercle vicieux. Au départ ça va peut-être te faire du bien, t'as l'impression que ça te soulage, ça te fais un effet frais dans la tête,
mais comment te dire, le marketing a ces bienfaits pour que t'ai envie à chaque fois d'acheter lui, et de te dire c'est lui qu'il me faut.
Alors que tu pourrais acheter des shampoings au fur et à mesure, si c'était vraiment un shampoing qui traiterait pour cheveux normaux.
Il faut juste arrêter ton shampoing et tu en trouves un autre.
-Ouais.
-Mais bien.
-Ok.
-Après à t'en recommander...
-Ok, donc j'ai compris.
Je ne prends plus de douche.
[rires] -C'est ça.
-Et si je veux en prendre, je jette tous les produits et je mets de l'eau déminéralisée.
-Exactement ! Oui, c'est ça !
-L'eau, que je mets dans mon fer à repasser.
-Exactement.
-Je suis un fer à repasser maintenant.
-Tu prends soin de toi, comme ton fer à repasser.
-Merci beaucoup Shirley, c'est cool. J'espère que ça vous a plu. C'est vraiment une vidéo différente aujourd'hui.
Mais ça m'importais en même temps de vous faire découvrir la chaine de Shirley qui est vraiment cool.
Pour la suite dans quelques instants, je vais te mentaliser, en tout cas je vais essayer de le faire.
Sauf que la vidéo ne sera pas ici, elle sera sur la chaine de Shirley, directement ici !
Sur sa chaine là, vous cliquez là.
Et merci à vous de nous avoir regardé et de nous avoir écouté.
J'espère que vous avez appris des petites choses dans cette vidéo. Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à nous le dire dans les commentaires, je les lis tous
et à nous le faire savoir en laissant un petit, léger mais néanmoins très beauty...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Avant de partir pour foncer sur la chaine de Shirley, n'oubliez pas non plus de vous abonner à la mienne, parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !